SIX GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JULY SECOND
TWENTY IS HER BY CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE VICE [inaudible]
ACCORDING.
IT IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
A MISTER SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM.
CARILLO HERE CERVANTES HERE.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON THERE MAYES HERE MS
ARYAN PRESENT SALAS PRESIDENT
WALDRON HERE.
MCCARTY.
WE HAVE A QUORUM A WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA.
IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA LIKE.
UBER MISS CROWE SECONDED BY
MISTER MONTAGES OF MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GRAYSON.
AYE GRAYSON AYE MAYES AYE MAYES
AYE NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE
SALAS AYE.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
MOTIONS PASSED AND THIS RULES
NMA